Okay. We have a super busy week this week
and I just want to let everybody know what
we have that we are doing in case you want
to participate because we don't normally do
this much stuff.
So we have a full week this week of shows
and bonus shows. So we've got the hour show
and the 15 minute bonus show Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday. We do have impeachment
inquiry hearings live with my commentary and
the way that we've been doing it is a to schedule
the filming of the show to accommodate the
impeachment inquiry hearings. And uh, it should
not affect the time that the program, the
daily program is released. So today we streamed
on YouTube, youtube.com/the David Pakman show
hours of impeachment hearings, Lieutenant
Colonel Veneman, uh, and many other witnesses
today. Tomorrow, Wednesday, we again have
more impeachment inquiry hearings, which we
will be streaming live. It could be another
six hours. Join us at youtube.com/the David
Pakman show. Tomorrow we will have Gordon
Sunland at 9:00 AM, which will be a really
big deal, and then the afternoon session 2:30
PM Eastern time. Wednesday we'll hear from
Laura Cooper, the deputy assistant secretary
of defense and David Hale, the under secretary
of state.
They will testify that's on YouTube. Then
we get to Wednesday night, Wednesday night,
we have a democratic presidential debate.
It will be moderated by a Rachel Maddow, Andrea
Mitchell, Kristen Welker and Ashley Parker.
We will have that live on Twitch at twitch.tv/david
Pakman. Probably. We'll kick it off like a
half hour early and then potentially we'll
take some phone calls after and then Thursday
we have more impeachment inquiry hearings.
9:00 AM we are going to carry the hearing
on the YouTube channel with Theona Hill. Fiona
Hill is the former senior director for Europe
and Russia at the national security council
and also David Holmes, who's political counselor
at the U S embassy in Kiev or Kieve as it
is now, predominantly pronounced, at least
during the impeachment hearings. That'll be
at youtube.com/the David Pakman show. So it
is a major week. It's like more than double
over time, but it's okay because this is important
stuff. I think it's important to carry it
and we're going to be doing it in addition
to all of the news of the day on the regular
broadcast.
Next week we will have a short week. It's
going to be because of the Thanksgiving holiday.
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, that's it. And
then Thursday, Friday next week will be, we
will be off. So that is basically the game
plan. Um, and uh, we will continue covering
important events I think from, basically I
was talking to some other hosts. It's actually
really interesting what's going on in progressive
left media right now. The host I talked to,
which don't really include people from, from
certain wings of the left, but the hosts I
talked to that are uh, uh, you know, some
of the prominent left people we all are basically
prepared for. This is going to be an absolutely
insane year now, 300 and what a 12, 17, 350,
348 or so days up until the election. We anticipate
that it's going to be debates, hearings. We've
got the state of the union, which we will
of course carry live early in the new year.
So it is going to be broadcast show consistently.
And uh, of course a lot of these live events
and somewhere in there we have to sneak in
one of our famous six month vacations, which
everybody seems to be very, very angry about.
No, I'm kidding. But we will of course have
a time off in there. So thanks to everybody
who's been participating in the live streams.
I wish all media outlets were covering all
of this stuff, but even when they do, sometimes
the commentary is, is not the best. So we're
glad to do it. It's all available free. There's
no pitch here. There's no ask for money on
the YouTube channel. youtube.com/the David
Pakman show. Subscribe there for the impeachment
hearings, the Twitch channel, twitch.tv/david
Pakman for the debate tomorrow night and many
other things upcoming.